Dude. I, I mean, I'm just done with the internet, by the way. I've tweeted. I,
you know, sometimes I tweet, people get off. It's just getting worse and worse.
Sometimes I just tweet. And I'm like the other day I tweeted on Twitter,
they were like, oh, the, the women's, um,
it's the first time WWE is headlining. Uh,
women are headlining and, uh, eh,
the WWE whatever it is, what is it? Even? It,
it was the, uh, the wa yeah,
WWE first time. Uh, here it is breaking WrestleMania.
35 will feature the first ever women's main event when Ronda Rousey,
Becky Lynch and Ms. Charlotte battle for the raw women's championship.
And I just tweeted on top of it, retweeted it and wrote still fake though.
And like
the amount of people that were just like
you mother, like,
dude, it is fake.
It is fake. It's not real.
It's literally like saying the sky is blue. So these people are like,
so is every TV show and movie ever. Well,
why don't you say when movies are fake? Why don't you say I don't,
but you know what, if you did, I wouldn't give a
if someone's going to say, Hey, yeah, but you know, Austin Powers is fake.
I, okay.
Yeah. Cool. Who gives.
A?
You know why you're so sensitive wrestling fans turn me up in the headphones.
You know why you're so sensitive fans about wrestling.
When people say that it's fake because you are
pretending it's real. That's why,
so what if it's fake? So what movies are fake,
but nobody's giving a.
They get so bent up because they know, by the way they know it's silly.
That's why they bend. They get bent up.
Cause they know it's silly because they're 40 year olds wearing
spandex
with hair that looks like it should be on Axl rose.
And they know that it's silly.
If you don't look, you can be a fan of wrestling. It's not,
I don't even hate it. It's I, I, you know, it's a. It's a spectacle.
It's not hurting anybody. It's fine. I don't give a. I don't. I tell you what,
I'd rather watch wrestling than football,
but it is fake. So if you're going to say, oh
you, you don't. Yeah, but you don't say movies are fake. No, I mean,
I, I, I would say movies are fake. I just did it. And,
and if somebody did, I would give a.
So if you're telling me, I mean, dude, this guy,
I don't even know. There's so many of these people
so wrote. So is every TV show and movie ever. And I wrote, you've seen cops.
Why? Why do wrestling fans get mad when you say it's fake?
Because they've heard it a bunch of before. Okay. Because you know,
it's silly.
There are a bunch of hairband looking beefcakes with
white boots on putting faces in nuts.
That's what it is. And the announcement.
Oh, oh, oh,
watch out. No, no. Watch out.
Oh, here he comes. He's up on the ropes. Oh,
what saw fake.
Oh, how's he going to get up from that? I know how.
Somebody wrote. Just because it's a watch.
Somebody wrote like, dude, somebody wrote crystal, Leah, that guy.
And I looked at his whole profile was like wrestlers
and like masks and. Like, dude,
get bent. Like what?
W Y w I'm not even hating on it. That's the thing.
People just assume that that's my whole thing. That's what, when I talk about,
like I say like, well,
I'm going to tweet whatever people are going to take it the wrong way.
No matter what this whole,
this whole culture of, oh, they're done. What'd you say? What'd you say,
what'd you say done? What'd you say? That's what you said done. You hate rests.
You said wrestling's fake. I'm not disagreeing with somebody.
And this is not the Barbara Streisand thing. This is the wrestling thing. If,
if you're a wrestling fan and you heard me say,
and this is just the example I'm using, I just, because it's me.
And it happened to me. And it's the most recent one.
But if you're a wrestling fan and you're upset with me or a comedian saying,
yeah, but wrestling's fake though. And then you think, well, I can't him.
I'm not going be, Hey dude, Europe. Hmm.
Sat noise. Your sat noise. You're making, is this, is it sloshy?
Cause Europe don't, you know,
cause someone disagrees with you comedically, by the way,
you can't be their fan. I hear sloshing.
Yeah.